breaking tonight to paraphrase a
question from another impeachment drama
of decades past
what did House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff know about the now
infamous whistleblower report that is
fueling today's impeachment inquiry and
when did he know it we learned today
Schiff was tipped off about the
complaint days before it was filed
president Trump charges that Schiff may
have helped right it also tonight
President Trump is ramping up his
attacks on shift saying he may have
committed treason powerful Democrats in
Congress are threatening subpoenas for
the president's team and the president
is blaming impeachment fears for a huge
tumble in the stock market today
he's also complaining that Congress is
wasting time and energy on what he
considers and we will abbreviate BS we
have Fox team coverage tonight John
Roberts at the White House with the
president's full throated attack on
shift Democrats the media but we begin
with chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge and the revelation
about Chef the whistleblower and the
timing of it all good evening Catherine
Brett confirmation that the
whistleblower reached out to the
democrat-controlled House Intelligence
Committee raises new questions about
their motivation and potential political
bias in a statement to Fox News
Democratic Chairman Adam Schiff
spokesman confirmed quote the
whistleblower contacted the committee
for guidance on how to report possible
wrongdoing within the jurisdiction of
the intelligence community shifts office
deflected Fox's questions on timing
whether the whistleblower contact
occurred days or weeks before the
complaint was Declassified adding quote
at no point did the committee review or
receive the complaint in advance
chairmanship does not know the identity
of the whistleblower and is not met with
or spoken with the whistleblower or
their counsel at a previously scheduled
news conference the president who got
the story as it broke unloaded on a
democratic chairman I give a lot of
respect for the New York Times for
putting it out just happened as I'm
walking up here they handed it to me
that's a big story
he knew long before and he helped write
it too it's a scam earlier in the day
before the shift whistleblower
connection was known the Democratic
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee and House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
said the president's own words are proof
of wrongdoing they again pointed to the
transfer
dov is call with the Ukrainian leader
where mr. Trump as Solinsky to
investigate alleged corruption involving
Joe Biden and his son
it's unworthy of the Constitution United
States to do what he did in that call
and he admitted it to me said it's
perfect no it's not perfect it's wrong
with Democrats requesting more Ukraine
records and threatening White House
subpoenas Schiff said he expects blocks
so we'll have to decide whether to
litigate or how to litigate we're not
fooling around here though behind closed
doors in a secure facility the State
Department watchdog Steve linic met
congressional staffers offering what was
characterized as a quote urgent briefing
on Ukraine after one Democrat described
curious documents this packet of
information is simply meant to advance
the conspiracy theory that Muller's
finding that there was a sweeping and
systematic campaign by Russia interfere
in our election was specious on Thursday
the administration's former special
envoy to Ukraine
Kirk Volcker who resigned after his name
surfaced in the whistleblower complaint
sits for a transcribed interview with
house investigators Republicans accused
Democrats of searching for a crime
they've been trying to impeach him
literally from the day he was elected
they know the transcript is taut enough
Fox News asked the whistleblowers legal
team if there was a single contact or
multiple they told us their client
officially filed their concerns in
August adding quote there was no contact
between the legal team in Congress until
nearly a month after the whistleblower
complaint was submitted to the
intelligence community's Inspector
General